ces personnes-là sont extrêmement
actives parce qu'elles sont euh
effectivement elles s'occupent d'un
enfant malade handicapé euh d'un d'un
d'un de quelqu'un en fin de vie c'est
pour ça notamment que c'est compliqué
parfois pour elle de retrouver un emploi
et et et elle souffre de la
stigmatisation de la la société qui les
considère comme passives qu'il faudrait
activer euh par la menace de de
suspendre le RSA notamment euh et euh et
nous ce qu'on on appelle à davantage
protéger les personnes qui euh euh qui
dont les contributions sont essentielles
de la même manière qu'on a reconnu un
statut pour les pompiers volontaires
qu'on a reconnu un statut pour les élus
locaux qui peuvent se voir rembourser
par exemple des frais de garde d'enfants
les soirs de conseils municipaux en fait
il faudrait qu'on reconnaisse que c'est
ce sont des contributions utiles et
vitales à la société que de s'occuper
d'un enfant malade ou de quelqu'un en
fin de vie et que cela donne droit par
exemple à bah des frais des
remboursements de frais des droits à la
formation peut-être des des droits au
chômage des trimestres de retraite et
que on reconnaisse davantage
l'engagement notamment des femmes qui
sont dans ce soins des relations et du
vivant